les échanges diplomatiques se
poursuivent pour résoudre la crise
ukrainienne mais les etats-unis
maintiennent la pression le pentagone a
confirmé hier le déploiement dans les
prochains jours de 3000 soldats
américains supplémentaires en renfort en
europe de l'est en soutien aux forces de
l'otan décision qui n'a pas manqué de
faire réagir le kremlin il exhorté
washington à cesser de nourrir les
tensions
la correspondance à moscou de verre à
gauche manne
nouvelle étape dans l'escaladé de
tensions entre moscou et washington pour
le kremlin ces démarches des états unis
ne font qu'aggraver la situation surtout
dans le contexte des négociations sur
les garanties de sécurité mutuelle qui
peine toujours à aboutir comme l'a
expliqué dmitri peskov je vous propose
d'écouter
nous appelons constamment nos homologues
américains à arrêter l'escaladé des
tensions sur le continent européen
malheureusement les américains
continuent dans cette voie
de plus il ne s'agit pas déjà seulement
de déclarations provocatrices selon
lesquelles une guerre aura bientôt lieu
selon lesquelles tout le monde va payer
un prix terrible et cetera il s'agit du
redéploiement de soldats américains dans
des pays européens proches de nos
frontières évidemment ce ne sont pas des
démarches qui vise à désamorcer les
tensions au contraire ce sont des
actions qui conduisent à une aggravation
de ses tensions et c'est la seule
attitude qu'on peut avoir à l'égard de
ceux là
bien sûr les préoccupations de la russie
dans le cas présent sont absolument
compréhensible absolument justifié ainsi
que toutes les mesures prises par la
russie pour assurer sa propre sécurité
et ses intérêts
les mesures jugées nécessaires pour les
personnes qui assurent notre sécurité
mais très peskov a également précisé que
vladimir poutine ne me n'est pas de
discussion avec le chancelier allemand
et le président français au sujet des
gants de sécurité mutuelle mais leur
explique seulement la position veut
c'est écouter
non
vous savez il n'y a pas de vraie
pourparlers concernant les garanties de
sécurité avec macro déchets ces
pourparlers ont été menés avec les etats
unis l'otan dans le cadre de l' os c'est
eux néanmoins ce sujet est régulièrement
abordé lors des contacts bilatéraux le
président poutine fournit les précisions
nécessaires un sommet p5 est toujours
présent dans notre ordre du jour mais
sur le plan pratique il n'ya pour
l'instant ni résultat ni perspective
qu'un tel sommet se tienne
l'elysée a annoncé qu emmanuel macron
devrait s'entretenir par téléphone ce
soir avec vladimir poutine pour la
deuxième fois en une semaine selon la
présidence française l'appel doit avoir
lieu à 18 heures avant une conversation
avec le président ukrainien l'a dit mais
l'élastique est elle prévue à 19h15
mettrait peskov est de son côté resté
évasif quant à l'entrevue prévue entre
les deux présidents et préfèrent ne pas
en hausse et systématiquement ce type
des changes